皆さん
テレビ・スマートフォン・パーソナルコンピューター
ニンテンドー３DＳ・ニンテンドースイッチ
プレイステーション４
見すぎていませんか？
あぁっ！！なんてことだ！！
愚かな民よ！
私も含め
愚かな民よ！！
そんなことをしていては
目がっ！！目がっ！！！！
悪くなってしまう...
はい、というわけで
えー、視力が凄い落ちました...
僕です！
ずっと編集とかスマホ見てると
ほんとに目ぇ悪くなりますよ
皆さん、目は大切にしよう
なので、今日はそんな目の疲れている僕なんですけども
食べ物で目に何がいいかって思った時
もう、これしかないでしょって
いうのが思い浮かびました
こちら！
俺、今日テンション高いな
深夜だからちょっとテンション高くなってるかもしれないな
はい！！
ブルーベリーです
群馬県のブルーベリーを
わざわざすごい沢山の量買ったんですけど
これ1個どれぐらい入ってんだ？
あー、うまそうだな
てか、目によさそうだな
118個なんで大体、100...10個ぐらいかな？
110個ぐらい入ってます
もう、お気づきでしょう
ちょっと日々の疲れで目がちょっとヤバいんで
ブルーベリーをなるべく限界まで食べたら
意外と視力が戻るんじゃねーかと思って
ちなみに僕の視力なんですけども、
もうあそこに描いてある僕の、僕の肖像画すらも
ちょっとギリギリもうほぼ見えないぐらいなんで
120×24は、
2880！？
あぁ、けっけっ結構あんな……
まあ、ちょっと少なめに見て2800粒
ブルーベリーがあります
とりあえずだよ、
ちょっと僕が今食べられる限界の量まで
ブルーベリーを体に投入して
まあ、少なくともブルーベリーを食べれば
目がよくなるんですよ
何かしらのあれで。
多分よくなるんで
純粋にちょっと疑問に思ったのが
ブルーベリー何粒食ったらお腹いっぱいになるか
っていうのをちょっと調べていきたいと思います。
まあ、全部ブルーベリー食えば何とかなるっしょ！
まあ、一般成人男性の食べれる
ブルーベリーの限界量ですね。
ぜひ！！
何かの参考資料に。
こうやって１つずつ世の中の謎を
解き明かしていくのも
YouTuberの仕事ですから！
ブルーベリーちょっと全部置いていきます！
はい、では検証していこうと思います
いただきます！！
んふｗ
かわいいなあ、なんか
ブルーベリー食べるってなんかかわいいよね。
いただきます
え、これ洗わなくていいのかな？
凄い土の、土の味がしたんだけど。
大丈夫かな？
まあ、いいっしょ！！
どんどん食べていきます。
あ、めっちゃうまい！！
え、これ多分ヤバい食えるよ。
純粋においしい！
てか、体によさげ。
はい、100個いきました。
いやいや...
おいしい😆
いや、特に100個食ったところで体に変化はなく
全然、まだまだいけそうです。
ちょっとどんどん食っていきましょう
はい、300個食べました。
まだ、かろうじておいしいです😔
ただ、やはり300までいくと
ちょっとこう体にたまる感じはありつつも
まあ、ここで終わったら動画がつまんなくなるぞと
がんばります！！！
500粒…食べました…
はあ...はあ…はあ...
あっはは
はあぁ……
最高の感覚だよ。
たまんねぇよ。
あぁ...
みなぎるぜ。
ブルーベリーアイ...
ブルブルブルブルブルベリアイ...
あっはっはっは
はあ...
700個食べました。
あぁ...
ヤバいヤバいヤバいヤバいバイバイバイ
もう、いいかなって感じです。
でも、ここで諦めたら男が廃れちま(ry
ん、んんん、
んぐ、んんぐんぐ
まさか1000個食べるとは思っていませんでした。
さーせん
あの、先にちょっと言っておくんですけども
かなりもう限界です！
うあっ...
肩が重いなー
肩がなんか凄い重くなってきました
ちょっと限界まで
もうちょっと迫ってみようと思います。
では。
ブルーベリー…副作用......
わっ
よかったー、あー。
すっげー今更なんですけど
急に不安になってブルーベリーの副作用
調べたんですけど...…
特にないらしいです。
良かったー。
だめだ…
心では動けって思ってるけど…
体が動かない！！
すみません......
もう......
無理です...
まあ、一応結果的に1360粒食べましたが…
えー、やばっ
ねえ、真っ黒じゃん口ん中。
すごい、
お腹が痛くなります...
まあ、これで
これだけ流石にブルーベリーとれば
流石に目のほうは良くなるはず...
なるわけねぇだろぉお！！！！
～🎵
ヤバい、ブルーベリーどっかいった！